the dolphins bringing in jacoby
brissette one-year deal up to seven and
a half million
he becomes what the relief pitcher now
behind touah right or or i mean does
this mean at the threshold does this
mean they're out on trying to upgrade
with it to sean watson or russell wilson
that is going to be tua and jacobi per
set or is it just besets the backup
regardless of who the starter well i i
think they could you know sell that no
matter what and go wait we got a pretty
good team here we're on the up and up in
miami we do need a good backup just in
case our quarterback does get hurt
whether that's to uh desean watson
russell wilson or whoever it may be and
again you know common theme here there's
some there are some relationships
percent was in new england with flores
and brian george gatsey who's the
passing game coordinator there he's
going to know the offense he's the
perfect guy to come in and back up for
this situation but i think like you said
it mike from all accounts the way it
looks right now they're going to try to
ride with tua i don't expect relief
pitcher this year it's going to be like
hey it's you
until you fail
or succeed or fail to the point where we
got to bench you and then and put jacoby
per set in but i just find it unlikely
at this point that the watson thing's
going to happen and then like new
england and some of the other teams we
talked about they're they're into
framing their team and getting it
started now too and figuring out how
they want to play what's the kind of
offense they want to use and approach
everything with so uh it's a good
signing by them and it makes sense
brisette had his moments with new
england and they traded him to the colts
and he was ready right place right time
when andrew luck retired unexpectedly in
2019 and you know he had a solid year
they were five and two at one point in
2019 injured his knee
was never the same after that right and
then they fell and then they fell out of
love with him that's when they brought
in philip rivers instead of riding with
him last year peter king said yesterday
because this is another one that broke
there was like five of these that broke
during the hour that we were on and we
had to pivot to them with like okay
what's next here's this okay peter said
that the colts really wanted to keep
jacoby brissette so uh they still saw
something there in value
from him as a backup but the dolphins
clearly do as well and and that relief
pitcher thing worked last year with ryan
fitzpatrick and and look if there's any
hesitation and brian flores has already
proven to be a master right when it
comes to
shuffling quarterback on and off the
field without having a problem in the
locker room yeah do you think that'll
work again though now that's i mean i do
think it's it's year two now
you know it's like okay yeah it was a
rookie last year to us so we can like
all right we understand it all those
things but we've heard you know again we
have all those signals we have the
signals of everything we read in the
media leading up to last year and during
the year where there was a lack of
gushing by the organization about tua
who was the number five pick right we i
mean we read that some of the players i
mean yeah he's good but it was never
like oh my gosh wow wait till you see
this guy and do that you know it's it's
a big year for two all together and you
know i don't think they can continue to
do the relief pic picture picture thing
i don't i think it's going to look bad
on them and tua and maybe more cause
more dysfunction this year as compared
to a rookie year where you started
another guy and he had a little success
early on and you can like swallow that a
little easier as a fan or somebody
that's in the organization it'd be
interesting
there's a clear belief as you know
throughout the nfl that it's incumbent
on the team to pump up the starting
quarterback to be unequivocally and
unconditionally behind him to be the the
champion the cheerleader the one who
says this is our guy this is our guy
this is our guy to the point where i
think that contributed to the rams
misguided decision to pay jared goff
they felt so compelled to let everyone
know this is our guy right they threw
all that money away in an effort to to
convince everyone this is our guy when
within two years he's not their guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports